dès ce soir catherine tricot bienvenue
directrice de la revue regards michaël
darmon chef du service politique
d'europe 1 merci infiniment
catherine tricot dites moi si je me
trompe mais il fut un temps où après un
épisode pareil après une tempête pareil
un ministre était prié de démissionner
ce n'est pas du tout le cas de gérald
darmanin il sort même plus que soutenu
ou encore par jean castex ce matin qui
lui a renouvelé sa confiance
est ce que c'est parce que emmanuel
makonda pas du tout intéressant séparer
de gérald darmanin
oui il est soutenu les parents fort
c'est quand même heure mais cet épisode
les en effet justement ce que je crois
c'est que ce n'est pas un épisode c'est
à il ya une ac mais la kek vraiment un
élément très très fort qui intervient
mais enfin ça vienne dans une suite ou
depuis des mois voire depuis deux ans en
fait tout ce qu restée sous le débat se
cristallise autour de la question est ce
qu'il ya des violences policières ou pas
est-ce qu'il ya un problème systémique
et tout le pouvoir s'est arc-bouté tous
les ministres successifs
on en est déjà au troisième noël à
l'intérieur mais les premiers ministres
mais le président de la république ont
argumenté qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un
problème systémique et là je crois que
quelque chose est en train de un peu le
mur est en train de se fissurer se
fissurer ah oui je crois que notamment
l'événement en fait avec ce producteur
de musique mais c est clair tout à fait
c'est cette vidéo qui a été vue par des
fins près d'un million de personnes non
plus ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu qu'ils ont
entendu parler je crois que quelque
chose est en train de là on comprend que
c'est une question beaucoup plus
profonde qui doit être une
reconsidération de la politique en
direction de la police comment
reconstruire une police républicaine
c'est un peu ça qui est en jeu mais cela
n'a pas coûté gérald darmanin son poste
non parce que ce qui est intéressant
pour eux quand précisément c'est cet
événement terrible sidérant et ses
images que l'on a vues au fond pour la
première fois d'habitude on a plutôt
l'habitude de voir ces images en
provenance d'outre-atlantique
on les voyait donc arriver chez nous en
fait elles ont un effet paradoxal elles
ont été évidemment elles ont un impact
considérable et renforce l'idée que
c'est une mais que celle agissements les
minorités et on le voit à travers les
également les études d'opinion qui
sortent cette semaine les français
considèrent qu effectivement ce qu'ils
ont vu et absolument révoltant
et doit être évident passibles de
condamnations et même de sortie de la
police mais pourquoi parce qu'ils
considèrent que dans l'eure dans son
immense majorité la police effectivement
n'est pas associée à ce type de tissu
donc c'est intéressant parce que c'est
effectivement un effet paradoxal
pourquoi ces mais aussi comment
dirais-je un événement qui est au centre
de la chronique politique c'est parce
qu'on est au centre du clivage qu'à
dessiner aussi le président république
et singulièrement en plaçant gérald en
mana ce poste là entre la droite et la
gauche
la grande décision de mener de macron
c'est d'organiser au delà de la vitrine
du en même temps les équilibres de son
de son pouvoir son carburant électorale
pour 2022
sur le centre droit est bien évidemment
en se mettant sur les histoires et sert
les propos de porter en général par la
droite et par ceux qui sont pour une
forces régaliennes pour autant gérald
darmanin quand même été recadré par
l'entourage des manuels maquereau en off
un maquereau nist du premier cercle a
confié ceci à nos confrères du monde
le problème ce n'est pas sa ligne je
cite darmanin a été nommé abobo
précisément pour muscler la jambre
régaliennes du président mais sa gestion
chaotique et vous le disiez il sort pas
non plus renforcée quand même oui tout à
fait ce que je pense c'est que il est là
pas du tout par hasard
est ce que viennent de dire à quelle
date on est tout à fait exact de dire
que c'est pas du tout à hazard de
casting c'est pas une erreur de casting
néanmoins ce que je pense c'est qu'il en
fait trop et au point que ça finit quand
même par fragiliser parce qu'en effet
dans le monde
il était également rapporté une colère
des manuels macron dix ans mais dans
quelle situation vous me mettez c'est à
dire je me retrouve à être mis à l'index
en france et à l'étranger comme étant un
président et un pouvoir liberticide
ce qui est quand même à fronts renversés
par rapport à l'image qu'il avait voulu
incarner pour une réforme soutenue par
les français en russe par l'opinion a
priori oui enfin
bernard manière générale les nuances sur
le texte de loi mais majoritairement le
projet sécurité globale et soutenait le
projet s'est accru de l'opinion la
sécurité globale mais enfin l'idée de ne
pas pouvoir filmer la police par exemple
ça je pense que c'est quand même
extrêmement contestée il ya beaucoup de
gens qui pensent que magna raison parce
que c'était justement l'intention du
législateur s'est donné quand même une
manière de se protéger ce qui dit quand
même une certaine défiance à dire que ce
pouvoir se fumer être filmés comme moyen
de se protéger ça exprime quand même un
certain niveau de défiance d'inquiétudes
à l'égard de la police moi je crois que
quand même il ya une vraie inquiétude
qui est en train d'infiltrer et je crois
qu'elle est a raison c'est moi je pense
qu'il ya une vraie problématique
maintenant pour remettre la justice dans
le lit de la république et que pour une
part certainement minoritaires mais les
ch mais qu'on laisse agir
ils sont minoritaires ceux qui agissent
de manière violente racistes etc
mais on ne sont pas recadré par leur
hiérarchie et on les laisse
avant c'est donc ça je pense qu'il ya un
vrai souci qu'on a déjà connu dans
l'histoire de france et d'autres époques
où la police a comme ça un peu
manqué à son devoir républicain c'est
une question qu'on ne peut pas laisser
déraper semble réagir et ça laisse des
traces chez en marche ou pas gg en
marche ça laisse des traces parce qu'on
a bien vu la difficulté de pouvoir se
positionner bon quelque part le travail
leur est facilité ils soutiennent au
gouvernement et soutient l'exécutif et
le président la république
après on voit bien qu étant donné une
fois de plus la composition socio
politique dans marche avec une forte
composante venant du centre gauche et du
monde associatif qu'il y a bien entendu
deux des sensibilités des émois des
états d'âme
de ce point de vue là c'est
incontestable là ça renvoie alors on
refuserait architecture générale de la
majorité tel que l'a construite et
menaient de macron et on voit bien que
également le l'heure de vérité approche
sur est-ce qu'il est qu'après ce qu'il
est possible de faire cohabiter des
sensibilités aussi antagonistes au sein
d'une même majorité mais ça c'est
quelque part un autre sujet ce qui est
vrai juste pour terminer sur les
policiers d'une manière générale le
corps de la police il faut aussi revoir
et on en parle avec des leaders
syndicaux cette semaine qu'ils admettent
ils disent aussi ces policiers subissent
énormément de secousses de convulsions
de tension depuis plusieurs années le
quinquennat vue à travers l'oeil ou la
vie d'un policier qui est en première
ligne c'est les gilets jaunes arrivant
des retraites le land le terrorisme
les manifestations les contrôles locaux
vides c'est un état d'épuisement général
et vous avez également c'est vrai ils le
disent aussi des deux par le fond
d'affaiblissement de débouchés
politiques se souvent et reconnaissent
qu'il ya une forme de jeu des raids de
présence de comportements liés à des
idées extrêmes et qu'il faut évidemment
condamné donc ça le problème n'est pas à
nier
je pense que le généraliser
digne et des dire qu'il ya un problème
général dans la police en tout cas c'est
pas le ce que perçoit l'opinion à
travers la sortie de cet événement et
vous citiez ce que disent emmanuel
macron ce matin endroit déjeuner avec
les sénateurs à mi journée il a dit bon
il ya une sur-réaction mais maintenance
en train de s'apaiser et je fais
confiance à la navette parlementaire
pour pouvoir donc acquérir dans cette
affaire on a vu aussi apparaître les
rivalités sérieuse qui était
probablement déjà existante entre gérald
darmanin et christophe castaner l'actuel
ministre de l'intérieur ne s'est
d'ailleurs pas gêné pour tacler son
prédécesseur s'était en audition lundi
écouter ça bien manifestations sont de
plus en plus nombreuses si on prend
l'échelle de 15 ans elles sont de plus
en plus violente
pas toujours pas tout le temps
évidemment mais c'est le cas pour une
grande partie notamment la plaque
parisienne de grandes villes de province
et peut-être que la difficulté de drame
c'est que les ministères de l'intérieur
a envoyé
je pense notamment pendant la période
des gilets jaunes mais pas simplement
des policiers dont le métier n'était pas
sûr du match 1 2 lors du match de
l'ordre manque d'équipement montrent de
formation et bim catherine tricot c'est
vise sans le nommer évidemment
christophe castaner à ou alors du cola
sarkozy je sais pas mais j'entends bien
oui c'est l'épisode des philosophes
directement castaner mais le problème de
l'équipement de sous-équipement de la
police on sous-encadrement c'est quand
même une politique qui remonte
louis alors ça c'est dit vous ce soir
mais c'est parce que disait gérald
harlin genton vient y visualiser jugé
gas je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
mais je me permettais cette petite pique
des raisons quand même ici il se prévaut
de nicolas sarkozy or je pense qu'il a
quand même quelques comptes à demander à
son mentor ceci étant dit ce que je
pensais que en effet il ya quand même eu
un problème avec castaner quand castaner
a quand même mis en cause lac et de la
clé d'étranglement
si on se souvient bien c'est à ce moment
là que les syndicats de policiers se
sont émus ont rompu et ont demandé sa
tête
et ils ont obtenu donc en fait moi je
maintiens ma position c'est à dire je
pense qu'il ya un problème de
reconsidérer de réaffirmer les missions
de la police
et la manière de le faire et quand
christophe castaner s'y est essayé c'est
à dire de redonner un sens démocratique
républicain à l'action de la police vont
regretter christophe castaner au
ministère de l'intérieur bas ont dû à la
lueur de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui oui
d'une certaine manière c'est à dire que
je pense que castaner s'était essayée il
avait pris conscience d'un problème
parce que tout à l'heure vous disiez que
l'opinion publique ne s'en rend pas
compte que l'opinion publique ne se
rendent pas compte qu'il ya un problème
à l'intérieur de la police est une chose
que tous ceux qui sont des gens proches
qui ont examiné les sociologues des gens
qui font des enquêtes disent tu as
vraiment un hero van halen on appris
aujourd'hui dans la police qui est un
problème politique qui commence à
devenir grave pour votre prestataire je
pense qu'ils aillent danser sur pour est
prêt si je ne disais pas que l'opinion
ne se rendaient pas congé que l'opinion
ne considérait pas c'est un fait
majoritaire absolument identifier le
fait qu'il y avait des glissements donc
de ce point de vue là ça c'est vrai
christophe castaner il a savonné la
planche de gérald darmanin ou pas comme
le dit le parisien et vern article
aujourd'hui sur ce sur ce point c'était
quand christophe castaner savoure une
revanche sur gérald darmanin
oui bien évidemment on est dans une
logique de deux personnes qui sont en
train de régler leurs comptes c'est vrai
c'est de la politique c'est pas la
première fois ni la dernière fois qu'on
assistera ce genre d'événement coulisses
ses illustres soit en même temps qui a
du mal à fonctionner ça illustre
effectivement les approches les indices
différents ce que dit gérald darmanin la
cantine le nom pareil en fait il lui dit
quelque chose que les avertis de la
place beauvau ont parfaitement compris
il a mis en fait en cause la manière
dont le système général la doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre qui n'avait pas été
efficiente au monde et gilet jaune a été
au fond dévastatrice pour l'image de la
police et pour surtout pour des victimes
du côté des manifestants
parce qu'on n'a pas donné on n'a pas
armé connais personne qu'il fallait avec
les bonnes expériences dont on a vu un
changement de ce point de vue là c'est
d'ailleurs la nomination du préfet
l'allemand nommé par emmanuel macron
soutenu par emmanuel macron encore
confirmée par gérald darmanin qui est
venu ce sens et qui était censé réparer
se faire remettre en place un système ce
qui lui dit en fait entre les lycées
quand je suis arrivée place beauvau
j'ai déjà trouvé un ministère qui dépend
en état de marche et maintenant moi je
leur en état de marche et ça le message
entre les deux effectivement ils règlent
leurs comptes
d'une manière générale et bruno le maire
au milieu de tout cela qui tout seul
affirme haut et fort que la réforme des
retraites est bien la priorité absolue
des réformes structurelles il l'a encore
répété hier soir sur lci même si
attention il assure qu'il faudra d'abord
que le pays aille mieux rien de nouveau
sous le soleil
dans ce que j'ai dit sur l'attachement
que je porte à la réforme des retraites
je considère que mettre sur pied une
réforme des retraites pour que le
système soit plus juste comme l'avait
promis présent la république c'est
important et faire en sorte que les
comptes comptes sociaux compte des
retraites soit équilibré c'est important
aussi
et si le ministre des finances ne défend
pas les équilibres des comptes qui le
fera et michaël darmon vous parliez tout
à l'heure de ce déjeuner d'emmanuel
mâcon avec les sénateurs il leur a dit
autre chose et notamment sur bruno le
maire il l'aura bien dit que cette
réforme des retraites n'était pas du
tout à l'ordre du jour faut il voir un
recadrage où on n'a juste pas compris ce
que disait bruno lennon elle est allée
beaucoup plus loin il a dit il n'est pas
question de mettre aujourd'hui dans les
formes retrait sur la table parce qu'il
n'est pas question de faire payer les
générations futures
donc on va mettre la retraite dans le
temps très long donc en fait elle est
totalement enterrée en réalité parce
qu'il n'est pas question pour le
président tel qu'il est expliqué aux
sénateurs au d'un déjeuner de dire on va
faire porter aux générations futures
deuxième temps très long qu'il a comparé
au temps très long de la dette en dix
ans on a placé la dette sur le temps
très long on place la retraite sur le
temps très long dont certains vrais
recadrage à veut dire alors c'est
quelque part il n'est pas dupe
emmanuel macron pour coiffer bruno le
maire fait il ça parce qu'en fait il
fait aussi des offres de service pour
pouvoir remplacer éventuellement un jean
castex ou éventuellement un géoradar
mana parce qu'il sait parfaitement bien
que comme menez le maquereau en euros
continuant à être positionné à droite il
ira si jamais jamais ces deux personnes
ne font pas la faire et bien moi aussi
je peux le faire je porte une lecture de
droite est bien évidemment dès que bon
bruno le maire a parlé de de réforme des
retraites nouvellement on ouvre une
manière manier et bien tout de suite
elisabeth bornes
allawi mandaté pour dire n'est pas
question marc fesneau marc fesneau tout
le monde donc pour le maire c'est très
bien que ça ne sera pas efficient au
delà d'un positionnement politique et
d'un message envoyé au président en
deuxième lecture 4 août et non mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord je pense que
c'est mal du tout une gaffe et ça n'a
pas vocation à être mises en oeuvre
d'abord n'y a aucun espace pour ne
mettre en oeuvre tous les syndicats tout
le patronat la personne n'en veut les
parlementaires crise la rue bien sûr
suis donc il n'y a absolument aucun
espace pour le faire simplement le
réaffirmer ses re dire voilà je suis là
je suis bien le libéral que vous avez
malheureusement pas choisi en 2017 et de
loin en 2007 c'est pourquoi la primaire
de la droite mais je le suis toujours
le libéral qui vous avait parlé à
l'époque et il est là pour ça enfin je
veux dire olivier rochus a fini sa
mission politique ça je suis dacc dans
le parisien on peut dire quand même les
propos tenus en off par un parlementaire
en marche je le cite cette sortie de
bruno le maire est un signal envoyé à la
fois aux marchés et à la commission
européenne pour leur dire la france
continuera à faire des réformes
si on arrêtait de tenir ces propos les
taux d'intérêts flamberait immédiatement
on ne pourrait pas convaincre que notre
gestion est sérieuse surtout au moment
où on cherche à mutualiser nos dettes en
europe
c'est une théorie aussi qui tient au
tout par pas lui
et à des taux mais rien à voir avec la
position française c'est une position
générale en ce moment qui profite bien
évidemment à la france
je pense qu'effectivement on n'est pas
content à bruxelles en bon oui on était
satisfait de voir que les propos qui
sont sagement fin l'allemagne elle même
s'est converti à la dette
tout le monde se convertit à la bête on
en train de discuter de l'éventualité on
va voir ce qui se passe avec la hongrie
la pologne d'un plan de relance
considérable pour pouvoir la distribuer
donc au pays pour lutter contre la crise
donc je ne crois pas ça soit le sujet
quant aux marchés financiers
il accepte l'idée de bons l'instant
d'être sur le temps long avec la
confiance dans la signature des pays
vraiment choix ils ont pas vraiment ça
puis franchement ils peuvent écouter
aussi lcp et découvrir que au miracle en
fait tout ça est un peu de du bruit
politique mais quand même c'est que l'on
vient de voir deux ministres gérald
darmanin bruno le maire qui prennent
comme quelques liberté de parole et de
ton
est ce que ce serait arrivé sous un
edouard philippe et ce qui est un
problème d'autorité sous jean castex est
ce que ce premier ministre arrive à
tenir ses troupes pour le dire de
manière un peu triviale
ils remplissent mieux la case droite
finalement philippe n'avait pas besoin
de le faire enfin vous n'avez pas besoin
d'être aussi brouillon quand il y avait
philippe au premier ministre il était
très bien identifiés par tous là
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'un changement depuis ce
changement va justement ça c'est qu' il
n'occupe plus l'espace de la droite
parce que oui et de montée en gamme
parce qu'on arrivait à la fin du
quinquennat parce qu'on va arriver vers
la campagne présidentielle parce que dès
la rentrée dernière en tournant la page
très rapidement de cet acte 2 postes
gilet jaune emmanuel macron a dit on
sera jugé sur le régalien sur
l'immigration sur les sujets de la
sécurité ne soyons pas naïfs
il a même à ce moment c'était l'époque
on rappelait enfin du côté l'elysée a
rappelé qu'ils appelaient le syndrome
lionel jospin qui avait bien réussi
économiquement éliminé au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle sur la foi
ou la base d'une naïveté supposé liées à
la sécurité
donc
le schéma est très claire de ce point de
vue là et on voit bien que tout ça ne
fera que s'accentuer alors ça mériterait
une discussion parce qu'en fait en effet
ce que lionel jospin pour quelle raison
d'une neige aux pas at il été élu ont
rapporté que tu forcément la réalité
politique voilà ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya peut-être un calcul qui
n'est pas tout à fait gagnant c'est à
dire que là il ne donne l'aise et ne
laissent partir que ses ministres de
droite et tout ce qui en effet sont en
première ligne sont quand même d un
ministre soit vraiment estampillé à
droite soit comme jean michel blanquer
qui est quand même une version très à
droite du ministère de l'éducation
nationale comme on l'a pas vu
donc il ya quelque chose là peut-être
enfin je veux dire pour gagner une
élection faut rassembler là on n'est pas
parti pour ça en ce moment et simple à
la jambe gauche quoi ah ben oui là pour
la fin du très faible et des dom a
justement c'est dans ce cas et c'est
peut-être qu'il va faire demain
justement emmanuel macron qui a jugé bon
d'accepter une interview aux médias brut
médias auxquelles la personne
journaliste rémi buisine qui a été
frappé par des policiers lors du
démantèlement du camp de migrants place
de la république à paris
c'est une intervention qui à priori ma
porte est donc sur les méthodes
policières et sur la liberté de la
presse pour en parler avec nous dans ce
match des idées on accueille jean
m'assieds bienvenue jean vous connais
très bien sur public sénat vous
connaissez bien les codes de
l'information et de la communication
politique en ligne vous êtes streamer
politique sur twitch jean emmanuel
macron vise clairement le public jeune
demain en s'adressant à brut ou pas je
sais pas si emmanuel macron vise
spécifiquement un public jeune brut et 1
est un grand média plusieurs millions
d'abonnés qui touche beaucoup strates de
la population pour le coup et c'est
davantage un contexte particulier on a
déjà vu emmanuel macron s'adresser aux
jeunes sur des réseaux sociaux il avait
accordé des interviews sur youtube il
avait fait quelques quelques extraits
quelques expériences sur tik tok par
exemple où là on était vraiment dans une
tentative de communication là emmanuel
macron accorde une interwiew un média un
grand média web plutôt dans une
tentative de rabibochage avec les médias
web ça se passe mal en ce moment entre
les médias et emmanuel macron et
particulièrement avec les médias sur le
web brut est un média qui s'est rendue
particulièrement célèbre grâce au
journaliste rémi buisine qui a couvert
les manifestations des gilets jaunes or
on est précisément dans le cadre de
l'article 24 de la proposition de loi
sécurité globale dans un contexte qui
braquent considérablement les
journalistes de terrain comme rémy
buisine est évidemment vous
rappelez rebecca rémy buisine a été
frappé lui même samedi dernier par la
police donc là pour moi et mes lignes et
le maquereau il est patent dans une
tentative de communication vis-à-vis des
jeunes que dans une opération extinction
d'incendié rabibochage avec des médias
qui lui en veulent beaucoup et c'est
plutôt malin ou pas de sa part de
s'adresser comme ça directement sans
filtre à ce média brut et quels écueils
doit-il éviter il doit éviter
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'écueils à éviter
malheureusement encore une fois dans une
dans une opération sauvetage comme celle
dans laquelle il est actuellement il ya
que des écueils il n'y a pas grand chose
à gagner faut essayer d'éviter la casse
et c'est de montrer qu'il est toujours
un petit peu dans le coup et ce qu'il a
raison de le faire je pense pas vraiment
qu'il est vrai mais qu'ils aient
beaucoup le choix il a toujours le choix
d'accepter ou de refuser des interviews
mais vu l'état de ses relations
actuelles avec les médias avec la
quantité de 2,2 de rédaction qui lui ont
fait savoir leur réprobation de
l'article 24
emmanuel macron il est bien contraint et
forcé d'accepter ce type d'interview il
accepte de le faire j'ai l'impression
qu'on est un petit peu dans le même
contexte que la fois où il avait accepté
une interview avec avec bordas et et
plenel
rappelez vous c'était c'était au début
du quinquennat c'était un peu similaire
c'était vraiment dans un moment de
écoutez moi je suis ouvert je suis prêt
à discuter
allons-y discutons faisant semblant
d'être à l'aise alors qu'il ne l'est pas
c'est compliqué pour lui effectivement
le média brut est un média connu pour
être assez direct on va voir comment va
se passer cette interview emmanuel
macron va je pense être assez à l'aise
il est toujours assez à l'aise en
interview mais encore une fois
pour moi il ya que des écueils là il va
devoir affronter directement les sujets
qui fâchent
jusqu'à présent c'étaient les membres du
gouvernement qui s'occupait du service
après-vente compliqué de l'article 104
l'as emmanuel macron lui même merci jean
manifestez vous aussi vous avez envie de
réagir à ce que vont dire nos invités en
plateau il crée quand même l'événement
emmanuel macron catherine tricot un peut
s'attendre à un retentissement
médiatique assez fort après cette
interview pas moi je pense parce qu'on
ait fait un devoir s'expliquer en direct
eur sur l'article 24 est là il est quand
même attendu au tournant mais moi je ne
sais pas si je me trompe mais je pense
qu'il est quand même 10 et une
communication à destination des plus
jeunes parce que là il est quand même
aussi en train de décrocher dans la
jeunesse et donc il ya quand même un des
signaux d'alert assez fort dans la
jeunesse avec des problèmes économiques
et sociaux qui frappe durement la
jeunesse et auquel il ne répond pas
c'est à dire qu'il refuse encore et
encore d'ouvrir les minima sociaux aux
moins de 25 ans il ya toutes les
mobilisations que ce soit pour le climat
sûr
les libertés comme on a vu samedi il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes sèment dans les
mêmes prestations face et quand même le
gros des troupes s'étaient les jeunes et
puis sur les jeunes et me élise ou qui
réalise un président et qui vont à ça
crée une dynamique dans une dans une
campagne électorale je dis pas qu
évidemment le gros des le gros des
électeurs cdh est plus haché mais malgré
tout dans la dynamique d'une campagne
électorale ne pas avoir les jeunes ça
crée un petit problème entre nous et je
pense même qu'il faut les avoir c'est
que si on veut rappelez-vous balladur il
avait fallu qu'il se fasse appeler
doudou allez vas-y mon doudou précédé
d'un concert avec peu de résultats mais
ça veut dire c'est qu'il y avait bien
une opération de séduction des jeunes
parce qu'ils étaient en train de les
perdre on ne peut pas gagner une
élection présidentielle si on n'a pas du
tout d'accrochages dans la jeunesse
or la jeunesse est en train de
manifester sur plein de sujets elle est
aux premières lignes en première ligne
et en plus elle souffre et les parents
des jeunes sont inquiets de l'avenir des
jeunes alors mis en examen je laisserais
gérer je reviens vers vous j'ai remercié
je crois que vous voulez réagir
oui en fait c'est une fois de plus c'est
l'équation de 2to emmanuel macron qui va
être réunies peut-être dans cette
interview et par la suite c'est à dire
est ce qui est le dernier d'un monde
ancien ou le premier dans de nouveaux le
paradoxe c'est que on a un président
dans la public est jeune et qui a
difficultés de contact avec les enjeux
contemporains
c'est ça la grande difficulté c'est vrai
vous avez raison tous les étés les
thématiques dont les maquereaux s'est
éloignée ou pas assez occupé sont
principalement ressenti par les jeunes
en particulier pour moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé ces derniers temps au
delà de la crise économique c'est le
rapport au climat
la nouvelle conscience politique
planétaire c'est le climat des goody de
marche pour le match pro clima les
jeunes sortent en masse et maîtres sur
leurs pancartes
des propos contre les dirigeants contre
les contre le président et c'est à ce
point de vue là il doit renouer et
convaincre de sa sincérité et là il ya
beaucoup de travail des gens mais moi si
je puis me permettre je pense que il
faut rappeler que les opérations de
communication envers la jeunesse comme
ça one shot ça n'a jamais marché on en a
un ça n'a jamais fonctionné on a déjà vu
c'était jacques chirac en 2005 en pleine
crise du cpe qui avait en catastrophe
déclenchée une émission de télévision
avec plein de jeunes sur le plateau ça
avait été un fiasco il avait pas réussi
alors parler ça avait été compliqué et
je pense que c'est une erreur
stratégique que de croire qu'il suffit
de leur part
les aux jeunes sur un média web pour que
d'un seul coup il se met à soutenir un
président de la république quel qu'il
soit ça ne marche pas comme ça
les jeunes veulent des actes en fait ici
des citoyens comme les autres
fondamentalement s'ils sont contre
l'article 24 qui veulent le retrait de
l'article 24 et il n'y a pas besoin de
venir leur parler sur internet pour
qu'ils comprennent mieux pour qu'ils
acceptent ça ne fonctionnerait comme ça
c'est pas mais il faut les convaincre
c'est pas une grande masse de benêt les
jeunes ça ne marche pas comme ça
donc effectivement les marches sur le
climat c'est ça ce que demandent les
jeunes c'est désaxé pas ils demandent
pas venez nous parler a pas besoin qui
viennent nous parler elle a besoin de
dialogue ça c'est vrai il n'y a pas que
les jeunes tous les citoyens donc je je
je je ne pense pas oui c'est une méthode
pas l'envié c'est une ancienne qui se
veut nouvelle c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on est dans le coup
dans la prolongation avec emmanuel
macron des méthodes qu'on a vu arriver
avec d'autres présidents auparavant on
l'a beaucoup vu chez françois hollande
est aussi chez nicolas sarkozy une forme
de segmentation de la communication
politique ou de l'action politique en
segments quasi marketing quoi on
s'adresse à des clientèles à des cibles
on organise on va le voir sur le média
ciblés on pense qu'effectivement on a
obtenu ombre à obtenir un résultat
je crois que les jeunes comprendront que
il ya effectivement des données qui sont
métapolitique et qui ne sont pas
uniquement lié au fait qu'on leur a
parlé ce jour là dans le média qu'il
préfère et oui peut-être qu'il ne sait
bien emmanuel macron qui va pas dé
convaincre d'un coup mais ils aillent
leur sens là il va commencer essayé je
pense qu'on a on a deux millions
d'années faisant ça ne prend pas merci
j'en remercie d'avoir été avec nous on
vous retrouve dans sénateurs à domicile
est régulièrement sur l'antenne de
public sénat très bientôt un dernier
petit m il nous reste quelques minutes
que se passe-t-il à droite pardon et
c'était question aux sénateurs je me
suis trompé et pardon gens que se
passe-t-il à droite dernier petit m
jacob l'homme pas assez pressé c'est le
titre d'un article du parisien ce matin
le président du parti ait l'air veut
attendre les régionales en juin pour
désigner le candidat de la droite
un calendrier qui inquiète au sein de
son parti et selon le parisien il se
murmure que christian jacob miserait sur
nicolas sarkozy
sarkozy reste une référence très
marquante et bénéficie d'un soutien fort
au sein de l'électorat de droite a
déclaré le président en a l'air
un fuck you know we en tout cas qui ne
correspond pas une réalité politique
je crois que tout ça au fond raconte un
peu le désarroi et l'attentisme qui
était assumée à droite parce qu'au fond
on attend effectivement le résultat des
élections régionales et on attend au
fond une sorte une seule vraie chose
quelle est la réalité du rapport de
force que va imposer xavier bertrand à
tout le monde tout en se lançant tout
seul par exemple de la façon dont xavier
bertrand arrivera imposer son rapport de
force il y aura un départage ou pas mais
moi je pense que nicolas sarkozy c'est
c'est une affaire terminée bon plus il
est embourbé dans ses affaires mais
c'est au delà de ça certes même si ces
incertitudes de positionnement politique
sont pas deux qui l'a esquissé avec
emmanuel mâcon à tous et tout ça est
trop floue ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il
faut que la droite se reconstitue un
corps de doctrine une politique est à
mon avis le seul qui pour l'instant est
en train de le faire c'est xavier
bertrand dans le nord et moi je partage
votre avis et qu'on attend de voir un
peu ce que ça va donner
bon je suis pas bien placé pour donner
des conseils à la droite mais je crois
qu'il faut passer la tournée la page
sarkozy est en effet regardez ce que
produit bon ce que produit cette
politique dans le nord est ce qu'elle
est capable aussi de rassembler les
catégories populaires qui malgré tout
font l'élection il n'y a pas que les il
n'y a pas que les retraités il n'y a pas
que les jeunes il ya aussi tout le monde
populaire mais ce sera un enjeu très
important pour 2022 justement dans cette
région entre autres et de la politique
est menée dans notre france il ya un
enjeu très important vis à vis de
l'électorat du front national
en clair on voit bien que l air un
problème en ce moment d'organisation de
corpus d'unités l'incarnation et il a
été décidé d'attendre les élections
régionales pour voir qu'est ce qu'ils
allaient décanter de cela et bien
évidemment en premier lieu qu'elle va
t-il se passer avec xavier bertrand ces
jours ci il ya eu d'ailleurs quelques
rencontres un peu discret déjà pour
tenter d'organiser le départage entre
les équipes de bertrand les équipes donc
de l air et tout le monde est tombé
d'accord en disant on va d'abord attend
le résultat
un jeu mal et ce sera ce point ultime
merci merci infiniment à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ce match des idées
en direct sur public sénat fin de cette
émission on se retrouve demain à 18
heures et à 22h30 en attendant vous
retrouver mon jour c'est vous 17h30 au
rayonnement de chimie recevra olivier
faur premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée